[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça découvre la
Réunion ensemble vous allez paraît alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
comment il est
parle pas moins les misérables
plus précisément sur le 2 manache en
bourgade
va découvrir
la forêt avant c'est un espace naturel
sensible allez comme vous le décoincer
en France rien que ça même moins
dépenses avoir Gilles on retrouve mon
moment rien que la même Moka des danses
derrière Elena la montagne ni un soleil
à CrossFit comme si la nature déconnait
à la paradis pour nous rester
bonjour bonjour Comment ça va ça va bien
merci bonjour monsieur bonjour
c'est un outil qui permet de porter des
personnes à mobilité réduite aujourd'hui
on est sur le domaine à chambaux parce
qu'on était sollicité par le Conseil
départemental pour voir si tous les
passages du domaine Archambault sont
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite notamment par le biais de la
gelette a priori il y aura pas de
difficultés particulières pour faire
passer une gelette là-dessus il y avait
deux trois endroits un petit peu
litigieux oui on en parle avec les gens
qui sont là pour mettre les choses en
place d'accord et puis a priori oui ça
va tout à fait le faire il faut savoir
que la violette est utilisée à longueur
d'année d'accord ben pour visiter les
sites un peu inaccessibles le cirque de
Mafate le Piton des Neiges le volcan
donc tout au long de l'année nous
faisons des actions dans ce sens-là en
tout cas c'est les Gaïa c'est un beau
projet continuez comme ça on a trouvé
alors allez ciao ciao allez salut
[Musique]
ok ben voilà alors qu'on arrive à ce
petit portail là passe pas par là nous
ça fait le retour c'est une petite
balade idiot 15 minutes mais par contre
il y en a gagné plus qu'à reprendre le
chemin vers et ben allons-nous
décidément aujourd'hui ce petit sentier
nanmoon
bonjour vous voulez bien ça va ça va
j'aimerais faire un peu aujourd'hui avec
ce panneau là préparation d'une
animation on va cuire des scolaires dans
pas longtemps 75% du public qu'on
accueille sur des scolaires et tout ce
que vous voyez comme une petite pente
qui est ici sont les enfants qui les ont
plantés ah ok ça c'est une particularité
c'est que le but c'est le but
sensibiliser faire l'éducation à
l'environnement c'est reconnexion la
société avec la biodiversité avec les
espaces de la Réunion on sait que c'est
hyper riche ici d'accord et que ça ne
peut retrouver comme richesse comme pied
de bois parce que
si on parle des scientifiques techniques
une centaine de piles endémique ici sur
Donald Chambaud et là ce qu'on va
prendre avec les enfants avec un petit
liquide de botanique pour regarder ici
en gros on s'approprie le patrimoine
naturel en apprenant de nouveau mot oui
en fait et puis après le morveil par
eux-mêmes ils vont chercher les pivot
qui a ici donc de manière autonome avec
des outils pédagogiques qu'on a
développé ils vont chercher donc le
changer Corse par eux-mêmes le bois
d'eau Yvan Le beaujoliker et en fait
c'est une grande satisfaction parce que
quand le moment il découvre pas lui-même
et puis tu dois une récompense et il a
envie de découvrir d'autres en fait
bonjour Comment allez ça va bien ça va
bien Fabrice viens moi
de l'aspects Eden oui cette pépinière là
c'est une pépinière qui va alimenter les
espaces l'espace naturel sensible des
hauts d'accord donc lorsque il fait moi
c'est un suivi si la pâte à sucre les
semis sur les lots et il me fait la
traçabilité et est-ce que nous
retrouvons des biens particuliers que
par exemple
oui il ne peut trouver par exemple on a
du bois de Charles cette nouvelle
voiture qui pousse par exemple dans les
Hauts celui de mon vers le haut du
chasse VI associé d'accord là on va dire
nous on va regénérer à la forêt est-ce
qu'on a pas autant d'avoir tous ces
plans là aujourd'hui très important
des années et là avec la spirale et
dernier le département ce que nous veut
faire c'est que ne veut faire la
restauration écologique
je suis assez forêt surtout ces espaces
naturels sensibles et il est important
pour nous de récupérer très en forêt et
de remettre en culture et de repartir en
forêt c'est la restauration et les très
important
là tout de suite là tu es en train de
regarder par rapport les aménagements
futurs nous n'aura sur ce site à savoir
c'est des ruchers pédagogiques nous on
va installer ici sur cet emplacement là
d'accord et du coup ben justement pour
revenir sur le domaine de la chambre
là c'est quoi la personne histoires ici
le domaine là
Chambaud c'était l'ancien maître
Saint-Pierre
l'ancien maire et ben ça c'est c'était
sa case de villégiature d'accord et
cette maison là le département là qui ça
en 1996 nous l'a commencé la
restauration
en 2012 et c'est là que nous l'a fait
quand même des diagnostics d'accord ces
gens diagnostic là dire nous que ben
écoute aujourd'hui cette maison là il
fallait qu'on soit et reconstruire à
l'identique donc là la plus rien il
reste de l'ancienne époque enfin si en
fait nous là nous là nous l'a essayé de
préserver quelques matériaux que la B
sur l'ancienne maison pour voir que qui
vivait un peu comment il se passait et
que aujourd'hui
nous l'a mis enfin un appel à projet
pour
pouvoir occuper justement ce site et
c'est une association d'agriculteurs
Lazare que les dedans actuellement c'est
gaillards en tout cas mes messieurs OK
avec l'espace intéressants que les la
forêt des yens les vraiment gaillards ok
la Réunion nana Gaïa allons prendre le
temps vis-à-lit et tout ça on ne vous a
un prochain épisode de l'émission loulou
cette fois-ci sera dans la commune de
Saint-Leu pour que précisément à la
chaloupe c'est lui derrière la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]